hello everyone thank you for coming for
today's talk today we will be discussing
explainable artificial intelligence
techniques and how they can be used as a
conventional data analysis tool
uh so first let me introduce myself I'm
Maria sahagyan I'm a postdoctoral
associate at New York University Abu
Dhabi in the department of computational
social science and I'm here because I
really love to share my knowledge about
explainable AI
so machine learning uh before going to
explainable AI first let's talk about
machine learning a little because we are
connected so machine learning techniques
is gaining attention especially recent
decades uh they see the attention to
machine learning simulated a wide
variety of models which are designed to
make decisions in different domains
across across Academia and the industry
so um machine learning is a very
involved in our lives it's even more
involved than we can ever imagine it
starts from basic movie or song
recommendation on one hand moving to
criminal justice and electronic health
record management on the other hand
and the recent implementation of machine
learning and artificial intelligence was
the self-driving cars given the
criticality of domains that with machine
learning and artificial intelligence
techniques are implemented and used it
is very important to have highly
accurate models because one simple
misclassification might affect someone's
life
so moving through the idea of machine
learning is it takes it takes historical
data learns in the training stage and
then predicts on the testing stage based
on the data that it learned from so
let's say we have a simple example to
demonstrate to demonstrate let's say we
have we need to decide here not we but
the machine learning model needs to
decide here is it a husky or a wolf so
in this one it's of course predicted
correctly but in the next example we got
a misclassification and it can be
especially dangerous if someone wants to
adopt a husky anyway so what was the
cause for misclassification in this case
it was the snow because in the
historical data a lot of wolf pictures
had snow in the background and machine
learning models got confused in this
situation but we don't really know about
the reasons behind each
misclassification because we highly
sophisticated models use then the users
don't really understand how the model
came to a certain decision
so so how can we
play with this classification there are
two solutions basically first we can use
the simpler models which are logistic
regression linear regression or decision
trees or we can continue using the
highly sophisticated model coupled with
explainable artificial intelligence
about which we will talk a lot during
today's presentation
so what's the problem with the first
solution that I mentioned which was
using the the simpler models it is
because when we are looking with a graph
of accuracy and explainability we can
see that with simpler models are on the
part of the graphite explainability is
high but usually accuracy is not is not
that high so there is always a trade-off
between accuracy and explainability and
the higher we go to higher accurate
models the less explainable they are
they are becoming
uh so uh to explain
um to highlight the importance of
explainability I will just bring a
simple example let's imagine we have
applicants who want to who applied for
the loan and this uh and the analysts
who govern the data he is feeding this
data to machine learning model and the
model basically is making an automated
decision who would get uh who would get
the loan and Who Would Not So based on
this model's decision let's say someone
who was rejected in the loan uh his um
confused why he was rejecting it alone
because he has really a good salary and
good credit history and then he comes to
his analyst to know the reasons the
analyst doesn't know because the
decision was automated using highly
sophisticated model now let's imagine
the same situation
but after using this machine learning
model
analyst also uses explainable Ai and
after using explainable AI he can zoom
in on each applicant and see which
features affected the decision of the
model let's say the first one had
master's degree had annual salary which
was quite high and because of his
zooming in he will have answers for
every applicant who wants to know the
answers why he was rejected or why he
was given the loan so basically we can
imagine explainable AI techniques are
kind of local feature importances for
each of the applicants who wants uh in
terms of the features
uh so uh moving forward I want to show
how attention has increased towards
explained by artificial intelligence in
recent uh decades
let's have a look at some statistics so
what I did I did a basic search in
Google books engram which uh also a
search in web of Science and Google
Trends from all of these crafts we can
see that attention towards explain I
started increasing from starting from
2015. moreover the papers that are
talking and mentioning explainable AI
techniques they are getting published in
really good journals and getting high
citations like around 4000 to 8 000 in
just four years
so uh having this attention increasing
attention towards explain the research
question was uh is there a way to
utilize basically explainable AI
techniques and use them as a generic
data analysis tool and how can we
benefit from this
so uh before going and exploring
explaini techniques and understanding
how can we use them let's first
understand what are the usual
um data analysis tools that are used in
the literature nowadays and we can see
that the trend that has development a
parallel Trend with development of data
analysis is regression analysis which is
very widely used across every discipline
of science starting from a medicine
going to economics these are the papers
site papers number of papers in the
number of journals that use regression
analysis uh in their so we can see it's
quite popular
so uh having ex having explained uh
regression importance of regression
analysis and also seeing the attention
to explainable AI we can go finally to
the focus of today's talk
so regression analysis gives us an uh a
global view to the features to the data
and on the other hand we have
explainable ai that we just discussed
that it is giving a zombie view to each
of the
instances so now the question is how to
obtain a zoomed in view having the
instant view to how to obtain a global
view having the instant view which is
the we can use coupled regression
analysis together with explainable
artificial intelligence now I will uh
explain uh how we would do that but
first let me quickly go through which
kind of uh explainable artificial
techniques there are in the literature
so we understand which part of this
graph we focus and which uh kind of
explainable artificial intelligence
techniques we will be using for our
analysis so let's say we have data in
the Black Box model black a black box
model we don't know how I made the
decision and we have the outcome there
are three types of explainable AI
techniques which are a model explanation
model inspection and outcome explanation
so model explanation techniques where uh
we are giving explanation to the
logistics of the models how the weights
are distributed how the models are
working internals and also it is usually
working this way let's say we have a
neural network it is very complicated
model and after that we are using a
simpler model for example a simpler
decision tree to track how a Veterinary
network is uh each on each state and
made the decision so basically a simpler
model is replicating um more complicated
model and these kind of techniques are
model explanation techniques
model explanation techniques are usually
used to give visual or textual
explanations to the users throughout
training the model and it is like for
example sensitivity analysis and some
visualizations that can help the user to
understand each stage of the models how
something changed or what happened to
the model and the outcome explanation
techniques are the techniques that are
not explaining the model internals how
the model worked but only explaining the
decisions of the bundles and how each
what is behind of each decision for the
model for example let's say someone was
rejected in the loan like for that
person each feature how contributed for
him to be rejected or how contributed
for him to be like it's local feature
importances as we already mentioned so
having this said we are focusing on the
upper right part of these models which
is
My outcome explanation techniques the
reason that uh the focuses on this part
is because the outcome explanation
techniques are giving us the
coefficients the same size as the data
that we fit to the model and we can use
these coefficients to have more
sophisticated view to this data set and
among these outcome explanation
techniques I have chosen shop which is
uh which stands for sharply additive
explanations I will explain it in
details in a bit and it is a most recent
uh explained player techniques and it
cited around for 8 000 times
which is uh quite a lot anyway to
explain sharp and to explain how we can
use it in our regression analysis I have
to explain first sharply values which is
from a Cooperative Game Theory
uh so uh let's imagine uh we have
players and we are playing a game so
these players it is very important to
understand how much each player
contributes to the game first if we have
three players we need to consider all
their possible joining orders like which
one joined when and how much contributed
to the game so if we have um in this
case
play so uh in this case the value is of
the Coalition is fixed uh let's say uh
let's say red player joins first and the
thread player joins first we can see
that from the first uh picture that if
red joins first it she brings only 10 to
the gate if but we know also that the
Coalition value is fixed for example if
red and blue we are playing together
their value should be 50. it means if
the blue player is joining the second
not first he needs to add as much as as
much value to the game to get to reach
50 which is 40. but in case the blue
player was first and blue player brings
always 30 to get to the game and the red
player joins second she this time she
needs to add as much to get 50 because
we're a coalition value is always 50
which means she needs to bring 20 to the
game and so on
so we have three players playing this
game we have uh six training orders and
then to cut to calculate the sharply
value which is the marginal contribution
of each player we need to see uh from
each joining order how much this player
edits to the game and divide it to the
number of training order so calculating
sharply value it sounds like uh easy in
example with three players
but it is usually computationally very
expensive because when we add one more
player the number of polishes is
increasing exponentially so sharply
values uh usually cannot be calculated
for bigger number of players however we
can estimate it which does a shop which
builds the the explain player technique
which Builds on sharply values so what
shop does they are let's imagine we have
a data set and instead of players we
have features so each feature is a
player and each a feature adds some
value to the Coalition of features so
the value of the Coalition which is
let's say red and blue is 50 in this
case in that case the value of the
correlation is the quality of the
quality of outcome of that instance
so what shop does it it takes all the
features and takes all the possible
coalitions of the data features and then
samples from these features each time
and then obviously on this sample it
runs local models let's say regression
on feature samples and then suppose
again with other features from this same
feature set and then see if this feature
was in this sample as on the first
sample it was not on the second sample
how much was the difference of the
quality of the outcome and how much that
feature could add to if that feature
joins to this order
with our shop estimates the coefficients
of each feature the importance of each
feature on instance level so having
explained the sharply value now I can
talk finally how what sharp uh what
output shop gives and how can we use it
so let's say we have n times M Matrix
with four features which is our data set
but we want to get explanations for and
then we train a machine learning model
on this data set and let's imagine this
time it's a binary classification and we
have minuses and pluses and as an
outcome so shop takes as an inputs the
data set and the train model and it it
makes uh the same its output is the same
size Matrix uh as the input data and but
it ranges from -1 to one and minus one
being like a negative effect of the
feature to the decision of the model and
one being the most positive effect of
the feature on the decision of the model
for example if someone was rejected
again in the loan -1 salary it means
salary really negatively affected or if
we have coefficients for salary minus
one
so the pipeline of using expandable AI
is a conventional data analysis tool is
as follows let's say we have a training
data and then we do they of course we
get the training data data the real life
data is always very messy so we need to
do data cleaning feature engineering and
feature selection and then we need it's
this part is very important we need to
address the imbalance and missing data
issues because although some machine
learning models can take a missing data
as an input for example like GBM but
shop doesn't take missing data as an
input so we cannot feed any data with
missing values to shop after this
training the model and uh
and cleaning the data set within the
clean data set and the training model to
a sharp algorithm and it generates the
coefficients Matrix with the same size
as the Matrix Matrix we feed it but so
the suggestion here is that we cluster
this generated new Matrix of shaft
coefficient and instead of running our
regression analysis on the first
[Music]
having the big picture on the initial
data set we run regression analysis also
on these clusters based on shop values
and a running regression analysis of
this clusters based on shop values it
gives us a very interesting point of
view on a data set which I will show you
in a bit because I have done some
experiments
so uh for those who doesn't know who is
clustering it what is clustering it is
just grouping similar let's say we have
a data set and we need to group similar
data points together so that the data
point in the same cluster are more
similar to each other when the data data
points in the other cluster so uh the
basic the most basic uh clustering
technique is KK means clustering so in
this pipeline but uh in this pipeline
but here we were suggesting clustering
uh the user can use any type of
clustering although the k-means is very
easy and fast to use and um
let's say we have this outcome Matrix of
sharp coefficients and then we use
k-me's clustering plus karensky kalinsky
Hardware bus index so Collins keyhara
bus index it is basically an index which
is calculating uh which is helping us to
understand how many clusters do we need
for example this game is clustering if
you want to run k-means clustering you
need to specify how many clusters do you
want and how do we find this optimal
number of clusters it is we do the
clustering and we use kalinsky haraba's
index on them which calculates the index
between a cluster this which is a
an index calculating between cluster
dispersion and inter-cluster dispersion
and that's how if we have higher
kalinsky harabas index for let's say
four clusters it means we need four
clusters on shop coefficients
anyway so here I will bring the example
with uh on a real data that I I trained
with models and codashop coefficient to
show how this regression a clustering
and regression works so in this example
it was a logistic it was a credit
default data set so we needed to predict
if some applicants can pay the loan or
they will default
so when we do this uh regression
analysis in this case because it was
binary outcome we did a logistic
regression
we can see this is the odds ratio of the
uh of the features and we can see that
the most important feature is credit to
annuity ratio of course uh if you're
applying for the loan then it comes the
down payment uh down payment rate it is
also one of the important features and
mean of external sources which is uh the
the external money from external sources
that the applicants get so it's all
about money as we can see from this
importance to the loan payment and
amount of an annuity and income to
credit percent anyway so all the
important features that we can see from
logistic regression are all about the
income of the person and how can the
person uh cover the credit but then we
we move to the shop clusters analysis
the way that it was suggested to use
k-means clustering and then do the
regression analysis on these clusters or
we can do centroid analysis doesn't
matter both gives a really interesting
result and we can see that we got four
clusters when we did this k-means
clustering and ah and it's important to
mention that on this a big data set
which was we were predicting a credit
default the default probability was 0.4
so forty percent default probability So
based on this shop uh sharp coefficients
the clustering was done
we can't see but it clustered the people
on uh who who has higher default
probability in the first cluster and the
people who have low default probability
in the last cluster and uh which what is
very interesting for me in this case we
can see that the most important features
in the first cluster that people will
get a higher probability of default was
of course credit to a new integer ratio
credit to Goods ratio which is like what
goods people applied for the loan to get
good but also it was interesting that
email that they provided or via email or
no they provided their work phone or no
it it was also very important features
in this case so in this type of
clustering when you do this type of
clustering and Adobe announces on this
features of local levels because these
features uh coefficients that shop gives
us we are a local feature importances we
can see some features that are important
so for some people which are not
important for some other people and if
we use a regression analysis on normal
data we would never pay attention to if
person provided email or didn't provide
an email but in this case for this group
of people it is important feature
so this technique helps to shed light on
the data set and look at it in different
perspective to highlight features that
we would miss for for sure if we use the
normal data analysis techniques
uh anyway so uh so when uh this uh
Plastering was done of course uh so
someone might ask question let's see
let's say you didn't do the clustering
based on shop coefficients but you did
the clustering based on the data and why
wouldn't clustering based on the data
wouldn't be as good as a clustering
based on Sharp coefficients that's why I
did also clustering based on the data to
show that it's not as good as clustering
based on Sharp coefficients in this case
and so in this uh figure we can see that
the a so okay we can see that we
selected the most important features
based on the initial logistic regression
analysis which was credit to annuity
ratio created amount and current depth
on credit bureaucracy credit bureau that
like if we need to know how much depth
in total the person has so these four
features we wanted to show the
distribution in the data in the cloud
clusters based on their timed in the
Clusters based on shop and we can see
that clusters Based on data we are just
replicating the data distribution of
these features itself but a cluster is
based on shopvist features are
distributed really differently and in
first cluster and last cluster we can
see that the features are high and low
and the default probabilities are 0.71
and 0.11 although in the clustering
Based on data only the default
probability was around 0.4 which is the
default probability in the whole data
set so it means this clustering didn't
give us basically much information
also when we did this clustering based
on shop Based on data and we did the
logistic regression on the
the whole data set we we wanted also to
show the performance of this
logistic regressions on each of these
shop clusters and each of the data
clusters so we can see that for example
when we did a logistic regression in the
whole data set our r squared was 0.18 so
r squared is the goodness of feed how
features are explaining the outcome
variables so if it's 0.18 it's not a
quite well explained it means the
features are not very well explaining
the outcome variable but when the
clustering was done based on shop and
the regression was run on each of these
clusters we can see that the average R
square increased from 0.18 to 0.36 which
which quite a good increase so this was
calculated the logistic regression was
done on each of the Clusters and then
the weighted r squared device calculated
based on cluster size and taking the r
squared of each cluster
and yeah and we can see that r squared
increased and also
um the accuracy also increased uh
it increased from 0.84 to 0.87 in case
of sharp clusters uh yeah so basically
that's it but um I wanted to know how
much time we have so I could demonstrate
a if I could demonstrate something else
okay
actually you can ask I wanted to say you
can ask your questions but I want to
demonstrate how easy it is to use shop
in
one second
okay
so I wanted to demonstrate on this
example how easy it is to use shop in
Python because like the people who are
using the usual data analysis techniques
and regression they would say why would
I go to this much hustle and train a
model and then use shop and how who
knows how difficult it is to use it Etc
so I wanted to show that it is very easy
to use and generate the coefficients
here I used the Titanic data set it's a
well-known machine learning data set a
small one because I just wanted to
demonstrate how it works and then we
have here the target name which is
survival did the person's survival it
didn't survive and we have some features
like this what six the person had age uh
what kind of ticket the person take and
Etc is the person alone or family and uh
what was the reasons that people's
survive or didn't survive anyway so this
is uh Jupiter this is a Jupiter notebook
Google it works in Google collab collab
this is based on python free so it's
basically online python I I'm usually
using it for my work but it gives only
12 hours to work on anyway so this is
python-based environment and I will show
how it will be implemented so these are
the features of the data set that I
explained now what Xiao shop works we
just need to PP install it before we
move forward it's a very easy and fast
installation anyway here I imported some
libraries that I will be using during
this analysis then uh okay so this is
the data loadings I did some feature
engineering for example fill the missing
data and
um
so I distributed age so that we will
have age code like from which age range
is the person anyway this is just basic
data cleaning process after that uh what
was done is uh I used for in this
example let's say we need to predict if
a person survived or didn't survive
based on the variables we have so we
need to use forward some machine
learning model in this case I used a
xgboost classifier
XC plus is a gradient boosting based
model so it it was trained and we see
that uh it was a the prediction was 0.8
uh when the prediction accuracy
so let's say we train the model as I was
saying after that after model training
we just need to feed like the trained
model here the pred model which is which
was the trend model to shop explainer
and then shop of shop values are
generated based on V6 planar and X which
was our initial data set so when we
generate this shop uh sharp values
we can use this Matrix for different
visualizations for example here it is uh
the global feature importance based on
shop values we can see for example
um so if the features has high value
which means uh in this case females had
a female was encoded one and male was
encoded zero if the feature has high
value which means uh he had the person
has higher probability to survive
because the person is on the right side
of his uh office
graph and if the feature had lower lower
value which means male they are on the
other side which they had lower
probability to survive but for example
in here the title code it was Mr Mrs or
other higher titles so if the person had
higher title for example doctor or some
other kind of titles it was important in
the model's decision that he was
survived it's also important to see that
family size bigger family size also
contributed the person not being
survived because uh the person had to
take care of the family and gather them
together and people who were alone had
higher probability to survive anyway it
gives a sharp values not only we can do
the regression analysis and clustering
on the shop values but also it gives us
very interesting view of the features
because when we trained with xgboost
the the feature importances were just
like this we don't have this kind of
detailed feature importances about each
person each kind of
feature and like detailed explanation
also then we have this
this is how it looks when we want for
just one instance to see for example why
Rose uh from famous Titanic movie
survived and we can see that
um for example here the blue features
are the ones who are making her
probability to survive lower and the
right feature right features you know
right they are making the probability
pushing to uh to up so we can see that
each feature here has some local
importance for example her family size
were was uh four so it was decreasing
her probability
but for example she was female and it
was increasing the probability to
survive to 0.78 anyway the the total
probability of her survival was 82 and
uh sharp explains uh explains
how each feature contributed to that uh
yeah that's it uh thank you you can ask
your questions now
any questions
um okay this was a great presentation uh
so my question is um so shape transforms
the original X values to Z values so by
using some linear transformation like
binary can you explain that part and
maybe bring in Practical example for
example like you're predicting the price
of the house and you have like two
features like the number of the bedrooms
like two and like the square area like
how this transformation of the original
data to Binary format happens it's not a
binary format it's uh it's like uh
values from minus one to one but it can
be 0.7 it can be minus 0.2 it's not a
binary format it's just the same size
Matrix as initial Matrix but it gives us
a feature importances for each instance
in a local level like not a global
feature importance but local uh but I
will explain how it works so let's
imagine we have uh not two features
let's imagine we have three features a
data set with free features house price
depending on let's say the location
um what else number of rooms a location
number of rooms and maybe something else
let's say pets allowed are not allowed
in this house so based on this the house
prices this uh is uh decided and then we
give these values to shop and what shop
does it takes a first it takes to uh we
have free features ABC and then shop the
algorithms Awards as follows it takes
two features together and then it runs a
linear regression locally with these two
features and then it samples again
another two features and then it runs
linear regression locally or yeah and
then it samples of all three features
depending on from which order each
feature joined like two features and
then adds one more feature and runs the
regression locally and each time it
tracks how this local linear model
changed after adding one more feature
teacher and based on this it calculates
the features marginal contribution to
this Coalition which decides the house
price so then calculating this marginal
contribution locally it gives us each
features like let's say feature that
pets are not allowed or allowed in this
house it it was contributing 0.1 based
on this local linear regressions that it
runs and then calculates the marginal
contribution each feature added when the
feature joins to the order that's how it
transforms the initial data to these
coefficients which is local feature
importances I don't know if I could
answer I would use actually whiteboard
but I don't know if I'm allowed
oh
yeah
but did I answer your question or should
I continue on the Whiteboard that's good
yeah my question was more like
um let's say if you're running a
regression model that no longer will be
like an instance explanation right
so how is the instance explanation like
um done
so let's say like if you have just one
row of like that you're trying to
explain so if you're running a
regression model so you can't run a
regression model based on just a single
row I see so because you need to have
several data sets to be able to
construct a linear regression model
right so that's I was trying to but
maybe we can talk later okay
foreign
yeah so first of all really good
presentation I especially like that you
showed how you could use explainers in
as conventional data analysis not just
about us interpreting the explanation so
I'm just curious if you have other
examples of where you can use explainers
within a data analysis pipeline uh yes I
actually it was my dissertation so I did
a lot of examples on different data sets
but there is another technique which is
similar to shop which called it's called
lime so lime is also it can be used in
similar way ways shop but I used lime
and Shop both in the same context as a
conventional data analysis tool and I
find out that lime is not giving us the
Clusters as good as shop coefficients
because lime is not is not using
uh feature coalitions but it is using uh
like for example it is taking the
proximity of the of other instances to
instance of interest and that's how it
calculates
the the
wait wait I think I think I got lost the
question was are there other examples
yes I did on different data set except
loan uh I did also this example on uh
patient readmission at the diabetic
patient through admission data set it
was uh to predict if the person will go
to the hospital within next 30 days or
will not go to the hospital it was done
also on so this was classification but
this example works also in regression
linear regression example and then you
do the sharp clusters it's so bad I
don't have a picture here it was very
demonstrative when you do the sharp
clustering and you map it back to this
original data set you can see the
Clusters with for example let's say
let's say our data
oh no no luck
okay
thank you
oh it won't be
oh I have here nice okay so so it was
for example a linear regression it was
like this uh
data and uh this example I really liked
and when I was using linear regression
on this data it was just fitting one
line which I usually would do but when I
did this shop example a sharp clustering
and I saw that there are for example
some data points but based on Sharp
clustering they are not fitting like
this line but we are fitted like this
and uh yeah so many examples you can
play to with different data set it works
on regression it works on classification
just feeding the data and the training
model and it gives you the coefficients
which you can play with a lot it's
interesting
foreign
thank you thank you
thanks